Try My day, Joe Rogan podcast
by night all day. Do you think,
what's the short drive?
It? What's the shit?
You've had a long career in MMA long and
successful career, but it's very rare.
It's very rare for someone to be
operating at the same level that you're
operating in is like the cutoff.
Like once you get to about seven,
everything starts to just rapidly
declined. Like he'd just fall to shit.
Do you think it's an injury thing? Is
it a training thing? Is it just a life?
They didn't, they didn't, uh,
or at least they weren't able to single
out any particular factor in, in general.
But you know, there was a lot of
theories as to why that might be,
but they were able to track, uh,
professional fighters careers, uh,
over length of time. I think they had
some metro having, I don't remember,
but it's on the, it's on
the Internet. Uh, it, uh,
I do believe that they accounted,
they were able to account for a number
of fights too and weigh that against that
metric and see how that
may influence things.
But seven years was this magic
number, like six, seven years.
And once you start going over
seven years, your, your success,
your percentage of success
started just crumbling.
Like it was dramatic about how a guy
would be like 13 and three and he'd get to
seven years, then all of a sudden
it's like 13, six, 13, seven, 13.
He just starts losing just
about everything. Yeah.
Bj Penn's good example of that. Right.
You know, look, there's certain,
there's a certain drop off where the
person just looks totally different and,
and you know, we could
honestly look, it would be,
we would have to isolate a lot of
different factors to figure out any one
particular thing.
But there's so many elements that go into
being a professional fighter and being
successful at that. And so for let's
say we'll take Bj, you know, maybe,
maybe it is physicality,
maybe he's lost a little bit of a step.
His reactions are a little slower,
uh,
through any number of
reasons why maybe his,
his strength has diminished
maybe slightly or is flexibility,
maybe certain physical elements regardless
of injury or not have diminished
enough that at where they used to be.
It was an edge where it is now is,
is evened out or is or is below what is
necessary for him and how he fights to
be successful. Uh, maybe could
be beyond physical deterioration.
Maybe it's just mental. Yeah, exactly.
So maybe he's just not as motivated to
push in the same ways that he was or
maybe he's not able to,
I dunno, recognize, uh,
things that he was five years ago,
six years ago,
and seeing those opportunities and
being able to react on them quicker. Uh,
there's a number of things and
especially when it comes to mental now,
now you're getting into such a
subjective area that, you know, go,
go, pull that apart.
That's a really good point.
The mental aspect is a really good point
because who knows, you know, the only,
the only the person that's competing
knows, we really never have any idea how,
what's going on inside a
person. Yeah. I mean, for me,
I decided to take a after my Arlovski
fight and that was somewhat physically
based, but uh, most of it was
mental. I, uh, I just didn't,
I had no interest to go into any kind of
training camp to put myself through all
that again to then to fight again.
You know,
it's just for one when you start off
fighting and what those goals are too,
as you get further in and further
in and further in and, you know,
getting it 20 years of being a
professional fighter and being a top 10
heavyweight, uh, and arguably
and top five most of the time for
Shit, 16 of them, something like that.
At a high level competition. Yeah.
And uh, it's just, and youngest,
every UFC heavyweight champion,
that's right. Until that,
that, that son of a bitch,
Jon Jones came and beat me out by a
few months. That talented bastard.
Now you're the youngest ever.
Yeah,
just heavyweight champion instead of
the youngest ever UFC champion. But, um.